what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
evan preach if i have a white wife i
won't share my black culture with her
before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it go follow my
instagram at the links in the
description it's just pearly things
with a z not an s that's just pearly
things
same as the youtube title but instead of
the s there's a z
okay i'm about to about to start this
video share my black culture
are you gonna do the same you saw my
face
your face was like you this will happen
this is what happened yeah i was not
there with you but i just saw your face
and this is what happened you were not
really listening
and probably watching the game yeah
and then this [ __ ] was hold up it would
what the [ __ ] did you say to me that
that's what happened you could bring it
back
but you you you just
you didn't comprehend metal gear solid
what where
what happened that is the most iconic
video game
if i'm a stepdad for a white kid
i'm not gonna share my black culture
are you gonna do the same
oh
[Music]
that was beautiful it was instant it was
great
and then i can wait but there's a way
you look at him
after there's the first initial what the
[ __ ] yeah
because he's part of the big forehead
tribe i'm not gonna share my black
culture
are you gonna do the same
[Laughter]
[Music]
it went from bad to worse you went
that's
number one what that was number two
and then you look the eye that's number
three and fourth level is when you leave
what if your stepdad to a white kid
so meaning like if you have a girlfriend
and she's white
and she have a kid with her are you
gonna share your black culture because
you're gonna be the step dad so usually
as a step dad you want to share your
culture but
me i was just talking and i'm like no
hell no i'm not gonna share my black
culture like this is mine and
this is your kid so i want to see if you
guys like agree
since you know you're black man and it
could happen give me an example of
something you wouldn't share
[Laughter]
you already know i know you you know
what you were thinking
good content we got to make some money
oh
this is good like wow this is going
it's crazy what i'm african so imagine
like
to go to no you're not going to let her
eat your people's food
i'm not going to be the one who's going
to share that if you want to use it or
go get it like she can do it herself but
i'm not going to be the one like
sharing this what the [ __ ] did the kid
do to you so
you're not the one that's going to share
that maybe she's going to find another
[ __ ] from your
tribe that's going to be able to share
that bro and much more
i said the food part jokingly no and it
was real real
hey babe where are you going off to eat
some couscous can i come no [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] i only mean my
[ __ ] cookies oh my god but i'm gonna
eat the poo spoons later see ya
yes yeah she can't not eat the couscous
and have her poof poof eaten
oh all right here we go it don't work
like that you eat the couse
you eat the poof moving mad past that
you want to be a stepfather to somebody
you want to have them be in your
household and live by some of your
values but you don't want to share your
culture with them
then why would you take on the
responsibility of bringing them under
your umbrella
how does that make any sense i don't
understand this kind of language it's
like
i think i think a lot of people feel
very conflicted about interracial dating
and so they say a lot of this goofy
stuff none of this makes any sense
i want to preserve my culture then you
marry someone from your culture that's
how you preserve it the best way
possible
you don't go to marry other people from
other cultures not share with them and
think
if you're not passing it down through
your kids and your next gene pool
through your wife to make sure that your
kids properly assimilated your culture
is not going to be preserved it's going
to die with you
that's it that's how it functions right
there's a reason why a lot of folks from
other cultures
encourage dating within that culture is
for those
habits and that culture to pass down
effectively through both parents are you
going to take her to heat your people's
food
yeah that's a good question exactly that
me
so what you're just going to have
burgers with her and eat her people's
food
yeah i would maybe go more into her
culture and stay with her culture but
maybe i'll i'll keep my culture to
myself and
why would you date a girl seriously
who you don't want to share your culture
with me i'm trying to make calculations
right there
me i'm trying to put the mathematics and
i'm not even really good at mathematics
so this got me [ __ ] up
it got me [ __ ] up all the way [ __ ]
up nothing can stop me i'm all the way
[ __ ] up like it was it was it was
it was i was trying to and then
he was coming with some more [ __ ] that i
was like bruh
what huh it makes me laugh like if
you're gonna complain about cultural
appropriation and you don't want to
encourage it
why would you take and try to marry
somebody i i don't understand
just go with people from your culture
it's not that complicated
you know what i'm saying i still
you know what let me just press play you
say it better than i could
once again this is from our instagram
lives we do a lot of conversations with
fans so if you want to come
talk to us on camera follow us on
instagram and here comes the
conversations the spicy one
this is the thing it's kind of
interesting just thinking about this you
know like
i'm a second generation right and then
if she's white for myself my
my generation like the culture for me i
want to keep it for myself
i mean at the end of the day is the
person that's your significant
other it's like you're trying to be
pro-black by
infiltrate a white girl okay i mean yeah
that's what i'm saying you know i mean
you tried the data
that is exactly what i was thinking
he wanted to be umar johnson and seal
okay that's like big one
you can't kiss from the road and then
and then also be like
it's gotta be a dark roast sorry not the
social website
listen listen no that's
that's the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever heard
you're gonna not share your culture with
someone because of the color of their
skin
it is one thing like a stranger that
doesn't matter fine
but the person you're dating or your kid
what
this is the most confusing
nonsense i heard it was great that was
great but you can't just
be like remove the burden of all of that
of you dating a white girl or you dating
whoever you want
i thought you were raised by being i'm
not going to share my culture that's not
how
it works none of it works like that
nothing
works like that i feel like for me this
is like about woke points
yeah it's like yeah i'm dating a black
girl but i haven't sold out you know
what i'm saying like
i still put that [ __ ] in her place she
tried to eat couscous i'm like no you
can't no
no and you know what her little a little
pet name you know
she calls me boo boo i call her
colonialist
like no uh hey settler you can't
do that it doesn't it's just it makes it
toxic
yeah it makes it toxic supposed to be
your significant other you're doing that
whole [ __ ] and doing
insignificant other man it's not it's
not what it is it doesn't work like that
can you imagine it isn't you're doing
your vows getting married for better or
for real
you're like [ __ ] keep the blindfold on
i don't want you to see my my family's
wearing or eat any of other food
imagine having a wedding we're having a
wedding but you're going to be at the
other side of the table because you're
not part of that culture
you and your wife it doesn't work like
that you're not making anything better
you're making
that's hella dysfunctional yeah
hella like umbrella ella ella a super
dysfunctional yeah and that guarantees
that your step child will never accept
you
no you try to hide and keep them away
from a huge part of who you are
um and then what happened if you have a
kid with that lady that has a step child
so you're going to keep the late the
step child away oh no that's my son
you you a white [ __ ] but that's why
like i said man i think a lot of people
don't know how to feel about interracial
dating
they want to have their cake and eat it
too they want to
feel some type of way about white folks
but then also be able to date them with
a clear conscience
i'm saying you gotta go to therapy you
gotta have a conversation with yourself
figure out searching to do bro yeah come
you they can't do that
yeah it doesn't put me in a better place
than anybody but
know where things come from there's
nothing i could do
that whenever people say talk [ __ ] to me
i'm like yeah i know where that's from
and i know where you got that hate
but it's not like no no no no you can't
talk to me like that
because yeah that's my wife but
i don't share with the white devil it
doesn't
no you can't it sounds like you're the
part of you is ashamed to be with a
white person yes
does you does anybody want to be with
someone who feels ashamed to be with
them
no oh my gosh if i dated someone that
said that
i would be so offended that would not
work
ugh that's gross you have to find out
why the reason
why you're doing this because the why is
very important to be fair to him there's
a lot of people who have weird views
about interracial dating you still do it
you know there's people from like asian
families who will have yeah oh my gosh
i don't want to say it but oh my gosh
yeah there are guys that'll
they'll still date white girls and then
talk about
how they don't want to date white girls
and don't date them
like i have a black boyfriend we'll
never bring them home
because of how it looks you gotta sort
that [ __ ] out you gotta figure that out
you gotta prioritize yourself a lot of
people have to have some discussions
love is love no it's more complicated
than that unfortunately
trust me bro yeah when you have a father
curse john say he's gonna kill you if
you see a dog it's not just love is love
it's complicated it's complicated so
people got to sort their [ __ ] out but
this was weird
this was hella weird this was someone
who was coping
you know it was like it's like someone
who's heard about the sunken place
is in the sunken place but denies that
they're in the sunken place
like they're aware of its existence you
know what i mean they're deep in it
but they're like some [ __ ] happened it's
like [ __ ] we watch you
through an aquarium you deep in there
something [ __ ] happens yeah
no no no this is like the plot for the
movie get out
it's like you watch the movie get out
and still fell into the trap
you know what i'm saying confusion
that's all i gotta say anything else you
want to say i feel for the dude because
that's that's that's my homie
i know the dude i actually know him but
i was like bro what are you saying
what do you say i had and you know i
know the dude and i still have to give
it to him
hey you can't do that you come on the
live
i could know it no it doesn't matter
that's not dated yeah
come on the live talking some nonsense i
booted them off yeah but i'm not mid
sentence no no but we
are we are comparable come on that [ __ ]
you're gonna get what you're going to
get you're going to get with a lot
people are going to say stuff
you're going to read the comments it's
that that's what it is and we're going
to
if you say some nonsense you're going to
get it whether we know you're not we're
going to be fair with that we're not
going to give it
nobody those privileges we don't get no
no privileges no
white privilege no black privilege i bet
you there's female privilege i'm sorry
guys will say this but a guarantee a hot
girl comes on
they treat him different watch we're all
equal in this [ __ ]
unless you're really hot then you get an
extra 30 seconds
i didn't even i didn't i swear to god i
did not watch this before
okay i don't mind staring at some
titties
so beauty privilege so if you guys want
to see some more hit us up on ig
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below what did you guys think
about this conversation we want to hear
from you
oh my gosh
so interesting um
that video was funny i actually saw that
live on their ig
the not the reaction but the actual
video because
what does it matter you know if your
culture is important to you why wouldn't
you want to talk about it or pass it on
with your family
so i would agree those some of the
stupidest [ __ ] i've heard in a while but
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree
or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell while you're at it and i will talk
to you guys next time